Iraq's Prime Minister has declared an
end to the Islamic state so-called
caliphate and in Syria the last
remaining Isis fighters in Iraq are
surrounded by us-backed forces Holly
Williams travelled to a village in Raqqa
province where she met men and women who
fell under the influence of Isis and
joined the group she is in kobani in
northern Syria with what life is like
inside of Isis Holly good morning good
morning
America's anti-isis envoy Brett McGurk
said this week that the u.s. mission
here in Syria is to make sure that all
foreign Isis fighters still in Raqqa die
in Raqqa
but we've been meeting with a group of
former Isis fighters who either defected
or were captured some of them were men
others just teenagers
all of them served time in prison for
fighting with Isis and have now been
released and reunited with their
families America's allies on the ground
here in Syria say they've been reformed
over the law Abu Bakr al Baghdadi and
other Isis leaders led a reign of terror
a vicious interpretation of Islam
unrecognizable to the vast majority of
Muslims but Ali Hamid a former farmer
told us he joined Isis not because he
wanted to kill in the name of his
religion but out of desperation
Jonathan joy we were hungry he told us
and there were no job opportunities tens
of thousands of people are fleeing recur
as us-backed forces close in on the
extremists in this refugee camp
these indonesian women told us they
joined Isis in 2015 traveling 5,000
miles because they believed Isis
propaganda if you go there you've moved
to their place you go to the paradise
because you are in the real Muslim in
reality they told us they were abused
and their male relatives imprisoned by
the extremists because they refused to
fight they ran away two weeks ago they
said and a too frightened of retribution
from Isis to show their faces the
Earth's desolate stupid
not just knife you're stupid yeah we
deceive very easily Isis and its
so-called Islamic state prey on poverty
and ignorance they claim to be waging
holy war against the West but in truth
they've inflicted terrible harm on
Muslims Nora great reporting Holly
Williams in Syria thank you